salut cdp robbins chez monsieur corps et
jordi visite à dr weiss qui vient de
sortir un nouveau morceau
babacan pour les incultes et les
retardataires dr vince & dj d'eysines
kohl's de stupeflip
c'est aussi l'organisateur des soir le
monte id au nouveau casino
j'en ai profité pour lui poser quelques
questions alors docteur greenson en
étant la fois dj organisateur de soirées
producteur animateur radio et que
sais-je encore ça rend pas un peu ce
qu'il veut toutes ces casquettes
là j'ai pas de casque est bon élève
schizophrénie pas vraiment ça fait
beaucoup de travail beaucoup de choses à
faire
s'organiser trouver des dates faire
coïncider mai date de dj avec les dates
de gérard les dacia d'état textures et
xaxi d'être voilà panneaux non ça c'est
plutôt cool quoi on trouve notamment
tant que dj des hinkle 7 stupeflip là tu
viens de sortir en morceaux bien à toi
tu as mis du temps pour dr vince
viennent sur le devant la scène
j'étais déjà des départs sur le devant
de la scène quand j'ai commencé à être
dj c'est vrai que de travailler que
celui que stupeflip
ça m'a amené du buzz après en tant que
dj c'est vrai que c'est plus facile
d'exister si tu as des morceaux à toi
des albums des choses comme ça mes
morceaux et d'ensemble qui bien barré
heidsieck et où tu étais chargé toutes
ces idées c'est un titre l'aspiration
elle est venue
en simple en un morceau en trafiquant le
sampler voilà tout simplement après le
100 m c'est juste la basse voix le piano
après tout le reste c'est de la
programmation que je fais moi même c'est
un morceau pour danser ouais ouais c'est
ça je vais essayer certains sports j'ai
vu que les gens qui fait alors que le
morceau personne n'avait jamais entendu
c'était qu'une maquette toi tu d'autres
petites pépites comme bada d'amener
donnant réparation bien sûr j'ai encore
des morceaux dans ma boîte l'avant et
regarde y'a du disque derrière ya toi
sans play il ya de quoi s'inspirer
on sent différentes influences tu as
toujours su mélanger les genres comment
décrirais-tu badham baba electropicales
paye tout simplement j'adore tout donc
forcément pour mélanger c'est un peu ma
spécialité on a bien comme dit king ju
mixer du duduk surf rock avec lui papé
et des choses comme ça après de leurs
idées avec l'électro mon étude des
collaborations avec les rituels csip fi
des projets en cours toujours des
projets que gérard qui sort sa mixtape
là au mois de juin les u22 le lendemain
de la fête de la musique c'est la fête
du slip dans mon slip c'est la mixtape
de gérard baste et vous allez là trouver
directement sur le net gratuitement avec
des remixes dessinée dit enfin bon voilà
quoi
gérard base toujours laissent duper
philippe munck king ju bosse toujours
sur sa musique donc normalement il n'ya
pas quatrième album mais chettia des
nouveaux morceaux donc je vous laisse
juge peu
merci dr vince et puis à bientôt alors
merci à toi monsieur greu et au plaisir
et puis j'ai envie de dire baba